[Music]
on this Tuesday night BC catches a break
the reprieve allowing some evacuees to
return home as others wait anxiously
just looks like a nuclear ball Monarch a
lingering uncertainty the push for fire
Smart Homes as military reinforcements
arrive in the Northwest Territories
solving Canada's housing affordability
crisis we have to build them faster the
feasibility of the ideas being floated
China's once booming economy in trouble
there's a heap of trouble what's going
wrong and the Ripple effects for Canada
and high drama the race to rescue people
trapped in this dangling cable car
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us there
is a bit of a break in the weather in
British Columbia's fire zone some
much-needed rain fell today in the
Okanagan it's not enough to put out the
multiple wildfires but it is helping
keep them from getting worse nearly 200
structures many of them homes have
already been lost in BC's Central
Okanagan today BC's Premier and the
federal emergency preparedness Minister
toured the region seeing the destruction
for themselves and meeting those forced
from their homes
uh this is an incredibly fluid Dynamic
and dangerous situation
the emergency response teams are doing
the best they can in very challenging
circumstances and my best advice to
everybody is to listen to those
emergency Frontline responders
we have complete coverage from some of
the hardest hit regions tonight nitu
garcha and Alyssa Carpenter are in the
BC interior Jeff Semple is in the
Northwest Territories where a fire is
moving dangerously close to Hay River we
begin in BC where the Wildfire situation
can change in an instant of the 380
wildfires burning there now 14 are
considered to be of note that means
they're either highly visible or pose a
threat to a community one of those is
the McDougall Creek Fire now estimated
to be 120 square kilometers in size it's
been burning for a week on both sides of
Okanagan Lake it's already destroyed
dozens of homes in West Kelowna that's
where nitu garcha is need to a bit of a
respite in the weather in the Okanagan
today has that helped
that's right Don officials say it has
helped they say with the help of some
lighter winds cooler temperatures and
Rain they feel they're turning a corner
in the fire fight here and there is more
help on the way hundreds of firefighters
from Mexico and South Africa are set to
arrive soon but this roadblock behind me
leads to one of the areas still under
evacuations and it is still a very
anxious time for The Hundreds here who
are still out of their homes
the freers are into their fifth day of
being out of their Kelowna home yep the
family of five plus a cat and a dog is
living with friends Unsure how long
before they can go back home or if the
Flames are still a threat like they were
on Thursday when they fled yeah
definitely a sense of panic up and
around those places and everybody says
they're kind of think it could happen
one day but nobody's really ready feels
like I was definitely not ready I'm
wearing I have two sets of clothes
security and cell phone footage from
some workers briefly allowed back
Saturday helped confirm their home in
the Wilden neighborhood is okay for now
my neighbors were all sharing
screenshots of our uh of our doorbells
and and security cameras I've been glued
to my phone just watching like them
evacuee Sean Talbot says the fire moved
so fast they were sure their homes
wouldn't survive in that time when the
fire was coming
um I mean we were literally watching the
Flames approaching your doorstep that
mountain and you could kind of judge by
the trajectory and the speed that you
know I wasn't going to have a house by
morning officials estimate about 60
structures in the Kelowna area have been
lost
the cause of these fires has not been
determined but with climate change
bringing more communities under Wildfire
threat some are pushing for improved
building standards for homes as a former
firefighter who works in construction
Freer hopes this year's events will
further that conversation construction
methods if a house is complete then it's
less likely to burn and you kind of have
more control over that it's not just a
pile of kindling sitting there I can
remember 20 years ago having the same
conversation a lot of things were done
over the last 20 years but we're going
to have this renewed focus on that and
he says help from Community has been the
most reliable place for many to seek
support like I said our butt landed in
butter having some friends like this too
so you do cease the best of people
when these things happen I guess
another major concern here has been the
smoke there have been air quality
advisories and special weather
statements as the entire Central
Okanagan region has been blanketed it is
finally starting to lift and officials
noted today that that will open an
opportunity for more aircraft to fly and
for some people to see their destroyed
homes for the first time Donna all right
nitu garcha in West Kelowna BC thanks a
two-hour Drive North of Kelowna is
another major area of concern out of
control fires are still burning around
the lake there Global's Alyssa Carpenter
is in blind Bay where frustrations are
growing Alyssa emotions continue to run
high it's been an exhausting number of
days around here people on this side of
shoe swap Lake still Gathering up
supplies to help their neighbors on the
other side of the water and on the other
side of the water more confusion more
frustration it's really become the
community versus the bureaucracy another
load of supplies be being taken by boat
across shushwap Lake all donated by
members of one side of the water
destined for friends and Neighbors on
the other side of the lake aside from
the you know the concrete stuff like
food and water and fuel it's it's a
sense that somebody's got your back
Melanie Dyer drops off water food and
n95 masks even though she too is
evacuated and staying in seminar I was
two kilometers from the order so we we
did get out because it was too scary
across the lake in Scotch Creek Sharon
Taves has been trying to have the backs
of her entire Community but today the
exhausted food truck owner posted this
emotional video to Instagram saying RCMP
won't let her leave her home to serve
food to her community we've now been
locked to our hoses and have all this
these supplies and resources sitting
here and we're not able to go anywhere
many here starting to feel as though it
is the community versus those who are
are making the rules and enforcing them
Greg kylo is MLA for shoe swap I would
certainly think that an individual in
the community that wants to provide her
food truck and take it there why would
you prohibit or in any way impede the
opportunity for Sharon to do what she's
doing she's just feeding her community
kylo says he's looking forward to having
a few minutes of the premier's time so
he can discuss some of these issues with
the premier the premier and a couple of
ministers were scheduled to be in this
area today to tour it for themselves but
smoke between Kamloops and Salmon Arm
kept the premier's flight from going up
okay Alyssa Carpenter thank you from
BC's Shoe Shop we go to the Northwest
Territories wildfires there surround
much of great slave Lakes some rain
north of the lake has helped hold back
the fires near Yellowknife over the last
few days but concerns are growing for
southern communities such as Hay River
where strong winds are Fanning the
Flames the wall of flames moved with
frightening speed fire crews are now
arriving from Saskatchewan and Manitoba
to help Jeff simple is in Hay River
where people have seen how fast things
can get out of control Jeff
Donna this small Smoky town of Hay River
is surrounded by fire on two sides with
the closest Blaze to the South just one
kilometer away but reinforcements have
arrived
last week the town of Hay River came
this close to an inferno we're currently
evacuating earlier that day local
officials had received word that a fire
was heading in their Direction but was
still nearly 100 kilometers away then
without warning that fire arrived we
lost calms so we had no idea that the
fire was even coming towards us and it
just showed up on our doorstep way
earlier than expected the local fire
chief says the blaze jumped 80
kilometers in just two hours for a fire
to move that fast have you ever seen
anything like that before no no one has
with no working cell phones or Internet
the mayor scrambled to sound the alarm
and evacuate around 6 000 people the
biggest challenge was obviously comms
right not knowing how we're going to
warn them some escaped on planes others
by Road the wreckage from charred car
crashes still littered along the highway
this is what's left of the neighboring
Village just 30 minutes away but
incredibly Hay River escaped unscathed
and no one was killed guess I'm pretty
good flight attendant because I had
those planes loaded in no time so that's
how I started out right no it was it was
an exercise we were tested and like I
said we're counting our wins and working
through it they won that battle but the
war rages on and now they're getting
some backup
around 140 soldiers and military
personnel just arrived in Hay River from
Quebec swapping their firearms for fire
hoses soldiers are not trained to fight
flames on the front lines but they are
equipped to assist with containment
basically what we do is we search for
hot spots we turn over the soil I try to
dig as much as we can as we can and then
the helicopters come in we'll douse the
fire for most here this is their first
time fighting fires but at this rate it
likely won't be their last some of them
have back in the province of Quebec but
most our guys are new to this so they're
gaining experience as we go but while
the military is helping the weather is
not there's a small chance of rain this
evening but after that the forecast
calls for warm and dry conditions for at
least the next week
Donna all right Jeff sample in Hay River
Northwest Territories thanks in Prince
George BC at least three people are in
hospital after a massive explosion level
the building in that City's downtown
police say it happened in an abandoned
building around seven this morning the
explosion destroyed the building damaged
surrounding infrastructure police say
it's possible people may have been
inside at the time the cause of the
explosion is under investigation
there were a tense few hours last night
at West Edmonton Mall
[Applause]
the mall was locked down after three men
were injured in a targeted shooting it
happened just before eight last night
we are incredibly lucky that nobody lost
their lives yesterday that no innocent
people were injured
and that police were able to respond and
now gather evidence this was targeted
event
after reviewing security video police
say four people who were walking out to
the parking lot were approached by a
white SUV and that encounter they say
resulted in an exchange of gunfire the
SUV involved has been located police are
searching for those who were inside and
a fourth individual who fled the scene
well no one disputes Canada has a
serious shortage of affordable housing
the argument is about how to create more
and who should pay for it at a retreat
of federal cabinet ministers in
Charlottetown the Liberals heard from
the authors of a recent report that
provides some recommendations Mackenzie
gray looks at some of the options on the
table
this system is in a crisis they're the
housing gurus the Liberals hope will
change their economic fortunes what this
rental crisis is causing is it's
bleeding into an ownership crisis that
squeeze the focus of the Liberals
cabinet Retreat attempting to fix one of
Canada's most acute issues we have to
build more homes and we have to build
them faster some of the proposals here
over 2 000 houses have already Arisen in
less than a year parking back to the
housing crisis of the 1940s when Ottawa
built thousands of rentals for returning
Second World War veterans a lot of the
same policy instruments that we that the
federal government used back then they
could use again today approving
standardized housing plans and cutting
federal taxes on developments two key
ideas that liberals could Implement
quickly but without support from the
provinces and municipalities the bigger
issues won't be solved in the housing
crisis in Canada is so acute like 2
million units is over a trillion dollars
of investment now there's no government
that's going to have a trillion dollars
to put into this the candidate needs to
nearly triple that number to reach
affordability by 2030 and to help get
there the new housing Minister thinks
cabinet should consider capping the 800
000 student visas granted annually to
reduce rental demand a proposal getting
mixed reviews from cabinet colleagues
the crunch on housing has not been
created by immigration or International
students but adding volume to something
absolutely the premiers haven't raised a
cap on foreign students with me I talked
to the premiers a lot about housing even
if the federal government implemented
all the measures proposed today the
experts that spoke to Cabinet said it
would take two to three years Donna for
the impact to be felt in the Canadian
housing market
okay Mackenzie gray in Charlottetown
thanks China's economy spirals coming up
what's triggering the trouble
there are signs of a significant
economic slowdown in China once the
driver of the world's economy it is now
on Shaky Ground there is a debt crisis
in its massive property sector the value
of the currency dropped to its lowest
level in 16 years last week China's
stocks hit a nine-month low and
unemployment is rising it's all alarmed
major investment Banks which have cut
their growth forecasts for China Eric
Sorensen looks at what's going on in the
world's second largest economy
you can't miss China's economic downturn
it stares out from City skylines massive
housing complexes unfinished and
unoccupied the economy is slowing and
China has a mountain of debt from local
governments to developers that have
overbuilt to Consumers with steep
mortgages and little incentive to spend
as prices fall in a country accustomed
to growth
there is no deflation in China there
will be no deflation says the
spokesperson for the Bureau of
Statistics real estate is in an
adjustment phase he says business
analysts see it differently China has a
massive debt problem even dispensing
with the usual technical jargon they had
a heap of trouble
there's a heap of economic trouble
China's overall debt is 282 percent of
its GDP almost three times the country's
annual economic output household debt
alone mostly mortgages total more than
five trillion dollars U.S it's hard to
get the full picture the unemployment
rate for young people in June climb to
over 21 percent at that point the
government stopped reporting the data
China's leader Xi Jinping is attending
the summit of brics nations in South
Africa to bolster the economic clout of
the global South but the real test for
XI right now is at home there is that
pressure on the leadership because uh
president XI has taken ownership uh he
is the leader of the
um economy then if something is not
going right then people may point
fingers uh at him while Western nations
are raising interest rates China is
cutting them to Spur consumer spending a
Slowdown there could actually help
Canada to the extent that weaker Chinese
demand actually helps slow the Canadian
economy it might be a little bit of a
side benefit that we won't need interest
rates as high for as long to get
inflation down here at home
China's economy has long proved
resilient but it will be tested as its
population ages and Global competition
increases it's not going to be quite the
engine of growth in the coming decades
as it has been in past decades Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
tragedy after Wildfire is still ahead
the deadly Discovery in Greece
foreign
[Music]
people have been found in northeastern
Greece in an area ravaged by a wildfire
authorities are investigating whether
they were migrants the fire destroyed a
remote Village that's on a popular route
for Asylum Seekers from the Middle East
and Asia to escape the Flames dozens of
hospital patients were transferred onto
a ferry at the Port City of
alexandropolis another Heat Wave has
gripped southern Europe and Greece is
dealing with a second bout of deadly
blazes in a month
two weeks after wildfires ripped through
the town of Lahaina on the island of
Maui more than 800 people are still
unaccounted for it is a huge challenge
for officials who are trying to
determine how many people died and how
many have simply not checked in at least
115 people are known to have died during
a brief visit to Lahaina yesterday U.S
President Joe Biden promised more
Federal support and said rebuilding will
be led by residents
we will be respectful of the Sacred
grounds and the Traditions that rebuild
the way the people of Maui want to build
not the way others want to build we're
going to rebuild the way the people of
Maui want to build
but you know it's going to be hard
many have criticized the Biden
administration's response including the
initial 700 critical needs payment to
Residents to cover the cost of
Necessities Lahaina bore the brunt of
the Flames there the historic town was
almost completely destroyed but somehow
one house is still standing the picture
of this 100 year old house is
astonishing everyone including the
owners they were in Massachusetts at the
time of the fire they aren't sure why
their wooden home was spared they say
recent Renovations may have helped
including adding a metal roof and
Landscaping with River Stones instead of
plants
Ravine rescue next the mission in
Pakistan to save people trapped in this
dangling cable car
[Music]
they dangled for hours hundreds of
meters above a ravine in Pakistan and
tonight all eight people trapped in a
cable car are safe after a slow and
dangerous rescue operation it happened
in a remote mountainous region about 200
kilometers north of Islamabad Crystal
gemancing explains what went wrong and
how specially trained military teams
pulled off the rescue
in the mountain Villages around
battlegram cable cars are used to turn a
two-hour walk to school into a
four-minute ride on Tuesday Morning
things didn't go as planned two of the
three cables attached to the car snapped
eight passengers were left dangling in
the air the Pakistani news channel Geo
spoke with one of the individuals
precariously stranded
said I don't know how to make a request
but this is a matter of human love
in law should Rescue all of us as soon
as possible
he was asked if the cable car was used
often and said yes daily the interview
was cut short call dropped
military helicopters and rescue teams
were deployed about 10 hours into the
ordeal the first air rescue a student
was hoisted out of the cable car a
terrifying trip in its own right all of
the students on board were said to be
between the ages of 10 and 16.
Pakistan's caretaker prime minister took
to social media to applaud the rescue
efforts he also pledged to have all
private chair lifts inspected Rescuers
fighting against the wind and losing
daylight were forced to call off efforts
by air
zip lines were instead set up and
trained civilian teams got involved in
the dark another face emerged from the
Ravine every passenger eventually found
their feet back on Solid Ground ending
an agonizing day that began with a Rite
of convenience
yeah
Crystal gemancing Global News London
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is this Alpine Lake on the
outskirts of car cross Yukon we'd love
to see your Canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com and thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]